welcome to this video when it's Quinn
chili on over again yeah this guy
completely crushed me last time but
somehow yeah somehow came back from that
from that bad position so I'm going for
a different version of the King King
side Kings fianchetto here Bishop g5
that's early I've got 95 actually but
I've could have sex so it's not that
much of a problem so maybe here can i
play a 5-4 is this this is insane it's
probably in Cena which let's let's go
for that is bishop is not having many
squares now maybe you can still casts a
long for F for Bishop c5 its most as
possible my setup here has one one big
drawback and this is it has got very
little development mmm-hmm what now
cannot castle maybe like c6 yeah but
what's my next move with them
job that's not fun can i play I really
have to play some damn ugly Musa f6 and
c6 come on let's do that just that every
move looks damn ugly I didn't see
anything remotely remotely normal
looking but the whole that whole thing
is so shaky in the center okay so move
that I wanted to go here my idea being
to maybe get an ID f6 covering E 5 from
the side and avoiding anything on the D
file
interesting if they go F for no no no no
no no in d 7x forget about that one yeah
so Knight f6 maybe just nine f6 let's do
that might be really maybe I'm
threatening to take your form SF 39
doesn't have that many good squares and
FY sir is an idea f4 Bishop c 8f cakes
III
yeah the one looks quite weird
I know what he wants its want to deplane
on FFM was also fe for Bishop c8 gym
that looks a bit weak f1f for Bishop c8
takes only three that's Bishop d7 check
very strange but it sits there um yes so
what else Knight g4 is a move and bond
94 94 blunders the house fe 494 blunders
of peace fam so i take it takes c8 i can
actually just no I cannot okay after
playable I'm really not sure about this
but maybe I can take only 3 and x ray
castle short finally so takes on III or
mm let's do that
tis quindi 626 is very annoying yeah
also here in the next smooth Queen d600
the net wins wins the exchange
yeah Queen moves takes you seven notches
six that's a problem 906
time learning it's it's really it's
totally lost it's not even possible to
fired okay blah they had that whole
thing that look very shaky this opening
check maybe I was was ok but for it just
so awful I mean it I mean awful just not
how chest should be playing with those
um sitting there full of weaknesses and
so on okay um let's see Bishop e6 okay
is allowing this check or f4 actually no
f4 let's do it for I had a game earlier
against a where he had a completely
winning position but somehow screwed
that up so I really don't think that
will happen again just Bishop c8 and go
and King edge one or something it's good
that also might be good now I cannot
sacrifice check check
check Jim Quinn age 52 e 2 was the only
thing that I can think of here that is a
little bit tricky at least f3 rock
chicks nah not working
no cheek no cheek no cheek okay black
resigns yeah yeah that that whole thing
here that I plate is very very shaky so
f 5 and so on this is just very cheeky
but okay it's in some way that the the
way this this opening is played yeah I
wonder what's that so bad here maybe it
was Queen d6 was even stronger than that
yeah but this is this is then mf5
hangsen just a terrible position the
engine gives that it's a relatively best
ya mean I saw that but this is just like
this is just like blah yeah you just
have terrible pieces bed structures and
so on is just rubbish so um probably
that f5 idea is to be avoided hmm now I
don't know what is it that I should play
then
yeah i mean i can do this and then night
age 6 f seven or something like that or
maybe just an idea maybe just play in a
normal fashion yeah that's better
actually the so that I have 94 in case
of h6b should be three if he does
something similar then this is quite
good he doesn't want to have that oh
well maybe maybe this is actually the
best just normal moves I wanted to stay
within this kind of modern defense
spirit but that that position was just
totally rubbish yeah that is just
rubbish okay well thanks for watching